your client previously said that he'd be
willing to take a bullet for Donald
Trump what changed
several first I'm not sure when I first
talked to him I needed to know what
changed because I wasn't going to
consider defending him if he was still
ready to take a bullet for Donald Trump
I think the way he expresses it a series
of experiences with Trump that caused
him to question his character then when
he became president a series of actions
or reckless statements or vicious tweets
that caused him to question his
suitability in an office and then
finally the Helsinki conference scared
him in most Americans that he would
stand up and agree with Vladimir Putin
who attacked our democracy almost like
an act of war and opposed his own
intelligence community standing next to
Putin and I think Michael was very
seriously concerned about that and that
was a very telling moment for him
you think this wasn't intervention by
your client because he believed that
Donald Trump was a danger to American
moxie
I can't remember him using the word
danger to me I think he's dangerous for
our country but it's not about me it's
about my client I think he felt in
Helsinki there was a serious question of
loyalty to the United States and taking
sides against his own intelligence
community and denying what is
unanimously understood to be the truth
that Russia interfered on his behalf
showed Michael almost a mental
instability in the man that made him
of great concern as president have
knowledge alleged links between Donald
Trump and Russia I can't answer that
because it's a subject that might be of
interest to the special counsel but I
know that he has expressed concerns
about Trump's denying the reality of
Russia's intervention and what he knows
about or doesn't know about I think his
concerns about Trump are more in the
judgement and suitability issues and
about whether he knows much about the
Russians has he spoken with Norbert
honestly
that is a question I cannot answer if he
went anything he would be willing to
speak to anyone who is an investigator
whether it's Congress mr. Muller or
anybody else so I'm being careful about
my verbs he would be does he have
information that would be of interest
I've said that I believe he does
that's my opinion and we'll see whether
mr. Muller agrees in a course he refers
to be directed by a candidate for
federal office to make cash payments to
two women
why didn't he name but this was a
government prosecutor document
so when people are saying what is
Michael Collins evidence that he was
directed by President Trump that's what
he was talking about before he became
president I'm saying this isn't just
Michael Pollan Tucker this is the US
government prosecutors in the Southern
District who helped craft that language
for him to say and open a court that was
made to speak panting oh ma
speaking about accommodating federal
officers who directed custody talking
about not only no dispute he was talking
about Donald Trump and who does believe
that Donald Trump directed and
coordinated what he did and that hippies
did plead guilty to a crime it was
absolutely clear that Donald Trump
committed a felony a crime by ordering
or pressuring that hush money be paid so
that his political election chances
would not be harmed by the outbreak of
these two stories right before the
election and that he lied about it on
Air Force One he was asked did you know
about the payments and he said no that
is a serious allegation do you believe
your client had information that could
ultimately
I don't know whether he has what would
be the smoking gun information leading
to impeachment but just what happened
yesterday alone is the president nine
states according to the US government in
a statement read by Michael Kohn is a
criminal Michael Kohn pled guilty to a
felony corrupting the American political
system is what this violation is about I
don't think we've ever had a crime
committed by a present of this level of
seriousness and Michael Kohn and the
u.s. government prosecutor said so yes
Jay how much more is Michael Coren
willing to share
you'll tell the truth whatever in jazz
to occur